let's say i had the vectors
let's say i had the set of vectors
i don't want to do it that thick
let's say one of the vectors is the
vector
and then the other vector is the vector
6.
and i just want to answer the question
what is the span of these vectors and
let's assume that these are position
vectors what are all of the vectors that
these two vectors can represent well if
you just look at it if you just and
remember the span is just all of the
vectors that can be represented by
linear combinations of these so it's the
set of all the vectors that if i have
some constant times
times that vector
plus some other constant times this
vector
it's all the possibilities that i can
represent when i when i just put a bunch
of different real numbers for c1 and c2
now the first thing you might realize is
that look this vector 2 this is just the
same thing as 2 times the vector as the
2 times this vector so i could just
rewrite it like this i could just
rewrite it as
c 1
time
times the vector 2 3 plus c 2 times the
vector and here i'm going to write
instead of writing the vector 4 6 i'm
going to write 2 times the vector
2 3.
because this vector is just a it's just
a multiple of that vector so i could
write c 2 times 2 times
2 3. i think you see that these this is
equivalent to the 4 6. 2 times 2 is 4 2
times 3 is 6. well then we can simplify
this a little bit we can rewrite this as
just
c1 plus 2 c2
all of that times
3 times our vector 2 3 and this is just
some arbitrary constant it's some
arbitrary constant plus 2 times some
other arbitrary constant so we can just
call this c three
times by vector two three so in this
situation even though we started with
two vectors and i i said well you know
the span of these two vectors is equal
to all of the vectors that can be
constructed
with some linear combination of these
any linear combination of these
if i just use this substitution right
here can be reduced to just a scalar
multiple of my first vector and i could
have gone the other way around i could
have substituted this vector as being
one-half times this and just made any
combination a scalar multiple of the
second vector but the fact is is that
instead of talking about linear
combinations of two vectors i can reduce
this to just a scalar combination of one
vector
and we've seen in r2 a scalar
combination of one vector especially if
they're position vectors for example
this vector 2 3 it's 2 3 it looks like
this
all the scalar combinations of that
vector are just going to lie along this
line so if i go 2 3 it's going to be
right there they're all just going to
lie along that line right there so if i
and then 4
along this line going in both directions
forever any square if i take a negative
values of 2 3 i'm going to go down here
if i take positive values i'm going to
go here if i get really large positive
values it's going to go up here
but i can just represent the vectors and
when you put them in standard form their
arrows essentially would trace out this
line so you could say that the span the
span of my set of vectors
let me put it over here
the span
of the vectors
let me do it this way the span of the
set of vectors 2 3
and 4
is just this line here even though we
have two vectors there they they're
essentially collinear they're multiples
of each other i mean 4 6 is if this is 2
3 4 6 is just this right here
4 6. it's just that longer one right
there they're collinear
these two things are collinear
collinear
now and and so in this case when we have
two collinear vectors in in r2
in r2 they essentially their span just
reduces to that line you can't represent
some vector like you can't represent let
me do a new color
you can't represent th this vector right
there with some combination of those two
vectors there's no way to kind of break
out of this line so there's no way that
you can represent everything in r2 so
the span is just that line there now a
related idea to this notice you had two
vectors but it kind of reduced to one
vector when you took its linear
combinations the related idea here is
that we call this set
we call it linearly dependent
let me write that down
linearly dependent
uh this is a linearly
dependent set
and linearly dependent just means that
one of the vectors in the set can be
represented by some combination of the
other vectors in the set and a way to
think about it is whichever vector you
pick that can be represented by the
others it's not adding any new
directionality or any new information
right in this case we already had a
vector that went in this direction and
when you throw this 4 6 on there you're
going in the same direction just scaled
up so it's not adding us it's not giving
us any new dimension
letting us get break out of this line
right and you can imagine in three space
if you have one vector that looks like
this
and another vector that looks like this
two vectors that aren't collinear
they're going to define a kind of a
two-dimensional space
they can define a two-dimensional space
and say that this is the plane defined
by those two vectors
in order to define r3 a third vector in
that set can't be coplanar with those
two
right if my vector if this third vector
is coplanar with these it's not adding
any more directionality so this set of
three vectors will also be linearly
dependent and another way to think about
it is that these two purple vectors span
this plane
span the plane that that they define
essentially
right anything in this plane going in
any direction can be
okay any any vector in this plane when
as we say span it
that means that any vector can be
represented by a linear combination of
this vector and this vector which means
that if this vector is on that plane it
can be represented as linear combination
of that vector and that vector so this
this green vector i added isn't going to
add anything
to the span of the of of our set of
vectors if it and that's because it's
this is a linearly dependent set this
one can be represented by a sum of that
one and that one because this one and
this one span this plane in order for
the span of these three vectors to to
kind of get more dimensionality or start
representing r3 this the third vector
will have to break out of that plane
it would have to break out of that plane
and if a vector is breaking out of that
plane that means it's a vector that
can't be represented anywhere on that
plane so it's outside of the span of
those two vectors or it's outside it
can't be represented by a linear
combination of this one and this one so
if you had a vector of this one
this one and this one and just those
three none of these other things that i
drew that would be linearly independent
let me let me let me make another let me
draw a couple more examples for you that
one might have been a little too
abstract
so
for example
for example if i had the vectors
if i had the vectors 2 3
and i have the vector
0 7 2
and i have the vector 9
5 and i were to ask you are these
linearly dependent or independent so at
first you say well you know it's not not
trivial let's see this isn't a scalar
multiple of that that doesn't look like
a scalar multiple of either of the other
two maybe they're linearly independent
but then if you kind of inspect them you
kind of see that v if we call this v one
vector one plus vector two called this
vector two is equal to vector three
so vector 3 is a linear combination of
these other two vectors so this is
this is a linear
linearly
dependent
set
and if we were to show it draw it in
in kind of two space and it's just a
general idea that
well let me see let me draw an r2
there's the general idea that if you
have three two dimensional vectors one
of them is going to be redundant as long
well
one of them definitely will be redundant
for example if we do 2 3
if we do the vector 2
3 that's the first one right there
draw it in our standard position
and i draw the vector
7 2
the vector 7 to
so
right there
i could show you that any point in r2
can be represented by some linear
combination of these two vectors we
could even do a kind of a graphical
representation but we have done that in
the previous video so i could write just
i could write that the span
the span of
of v1 and v2
is equal to r2
that means that every vector here every
every position here can be
represented by some linear combination
of these two guys
now the vector nine five
the vector nine five that's what nine
five it's right there
it is
in r2
it is in r2 right clearly i just graphed
it on this plane it's in our
two-dimensional real number space or uh
i guess we could call it a space or in
our in our in our in our set r2 it's
there it's right there
so we just said that anything in r2 can
be represented by a linear combination
of those two guys so clearly this is an
r2 so it can be represented as a linear
combination so hopefully you're starting
to see the relationship between span and
and and linear independence or linear
dependence let me do another example
let's say i have the vectors
let's say i have the vectors let me do a
new color it's getting
let's have the vector and this will be a
little bit obvious seven zero
so that's my v
one and then i have my second vector
which is zero minus one
that's v two
now
is this set linearly
independent
is it linearly independent well can i
represent either of these as a
combination of the other and really when
i say as a combination you'd have to
scale up one to get the other because
there's only two vectors here there's
you know if i'm trying to add up to this
vector the only thing i have to deal
with is this one so i can do a scale it
up
well there's nothing i can do no matter
what i multiply this vector by you know
some constant and
you know and add it to itself or scale
it up this term right here is always
going to be zero it's always going to be
zero so nothing i can
multiply this by is going to get me to
this vector likewise no matter what i
multiply this vector by the top term is
always going to be zero so there's no
way i could get to this vector so both
of these vectors there's no way that you
can represent one as a combination of
the other so these two are linearly
independent
and you can even see it
in
if we graph it one is seven zero which
is
like that let me do it in a non-yellow
color
seven zero and one is zero
minus one one is zero minus one and you
can i think you can clearly see that if
you take a linear combination of any of
these two you can represent anything in
r2 so the span of these just to kind of
get used to our notion of span of v1 and
v2
is equal to r2
now this is another interesting point to
make
i said the span of v1 and v2 is r2 now
what is the span of what is the span
of v1
v2 and v3 in this example up here
i already told you already showed you
that this third vector can be
represented as a linear combination of
these two it's actually just these two
summed up i could even draw it right
here it's just those two vectors summed
up so it clearly can be represented as a
linear combination of those two so
what's it span
well the fact that this is redundant
means that it doesn't change its span it
doesn't change all of the possible
linear combinations so its span is also
going to be
r2 it's just that this was more vectors
than you needed to span r2 r2 is a
two-dimensional space and you needed two
vectors so this was kind of a more
efficient way of of uh providing a basis
and i'll i'll be i haven't defined basis
formally yet but i just want to use a
little i use it a little
conversationally and it'll make sense to
you when i define it formally this
provides a better basis or this provides
a basis kind of a
non-redundant set of vectors that can
represent r2
while this one right here is redundant
so i mean you know it's not a good basis
for r2 let me give you one more example
in three dimensions and then the next
video i'm going to make a more formal
definition of linear dependence or
independence so let's say that i had
let's say i had the vector
let me say 2 0 0 make a similar argument
that i made up there
and the vector 2 0 0
the vector zero one zero
and the vector
zero zero seven
now are these lin these are out we're
now in r three right each of these are
three dimensional vectors
now are these linear dependent or
linearly independent so are they
linearly dependent or independent
well i can't there's no way with some
combination of these two vectors that i
can end up with a non-zero term right
here to make this third vector right
because no matter what i multiply this
one by and this one by this last term is
going to be zero so this is kind of
adding a new direction to our set of
vectors
likewise there's nothing i can do
there's no combination of this guy and
this guy that i can get a a non-zero
term here and finally no combination of
this guy and this guy that i can get a
non-zero term here so this set is
linearly independent
linearly
independent
if you were to graph these in three
dimensions you would see that they none
of these
no three these three do not lie in the
same plane obviously any two of them lie
on the same plane but if you were to
actually graph it you get two zero let
me say that that's the x axis that's 2 0
0 then you have this 0 1 0 maybe that's
the y axis and then you have 0 0 7 it'll
look something like this
so it almost looks like your three
dimensional axis it almost looks like
the vectors i j k they're just scaled up
a little bit but you can always correct
that by just scaling them down right
because we only we care about any linear
combination of these so these the span
of these three vectors right here
because they're all adding new
directionality
is r3
is r3 anyway i thought i would leave you
there in this video i realize i've been
making longer and longer videos and i
want to get back in the habit of making
shorter ones in the next video i'm going
to make a more formal definition of
linear dependence and we'll do a bunch
more examples